皆さんパリピって知ってますか？なんか…
いや、決してパリピになりたいわけではないんですけども
パリピを見るとなんかすごい悔しい気持ちが出てきます
はじめしゃちょーです
すいません　ちょっと静かに行きますね
今日はこっそりやってる動画なので
パリピ皆んなつけてるってわけではないんですけども
こういうの見たことありますでしょか
まぁこれどんなのかと言いますと
身体の部位に塗るとそこがキラキラするやつでございます
これさ使ってるやつほんとにこれで
あたしモテると思って使ってんなかな
っていう疑問を持ちつつも実は効果あるんだろうね
多分女の人がねこうなんか露出が多い時の
このなんかねこの腕のこういうとことかに塗って
キラキラしたらそれをこう男がねこうやって
グラブとかでダンスしてるじゃないですか
ﾄﾞｩﾝﾂｯ ﾄﾞｩﾝﾂｯ ﾄﾞｩﾝﾂｯ ﾄﾞｩﾝﾂｯ ﾄﾞｩﾝﾂｯ ﾄﾞｩﾝﾂｯ ﾄﾞｩﾝﾂｯ
ってなるわけです　とりあえず人の目を惹きますキラキラしると
それできっとこれをつけてるパリピの女の方たちは
男性の目をこう…
俺パリピじゃないもんパリピじゃないからちょっとわかんないですけど
そういうですねちょっと目立つパーティーグッズみたいなもんなんすよ
ボディーメークアップなんで
おーこんな感じっすね
で、今回その肌をキラキラになるやつをたくさん買ってきたんで
あのー正直な僕の持論から話させてください
肌キラキラしてたところで
うーん　ってなりますよ僕は少なくとも
だってほんとにこれで肌がキラキラになることによって
意味があるのかどうかっていうを
今回検証しようと思いまして
上で今頑張って編集している人がいます
で、徐々に徐々に僕の身体がキラキラになっていきます
で、これは本当に意味あるものだったら
少ないうちにすぐわかると思うんすよキラキラしてて
キラキラしてますねって
すぐ気づいたらそれなりにやっぱ効果があるんじゃないかと思う
逆になんかどれだけキラキラになっても一向に声がかけられないようだったら
あんまりこれが塗る意味がないんじゃないかなと思います
っていうわけで今回はどこまで身体がキラキラになったら気づいてくれるのか
検証していきたいと思います　ではいこう
最初は少しでいいと思うんすよね
うわぁこれでもすげーな
思った以上にキラキラしてますね
これをこうやって
まぁ若干だなぁ
これわかるかなぁ手はすごい
でも若干キラキラしてますね
一回これで行ってきます　では
はじめ）オーケーっす
はじめ）失礼します
やふへゐ）お願いします
はじめ）ドロップしたんでそこだけ白でいければ多分大丈夫っす
やふへゐ）オーケーっす
はじめ）じゃよろしくお願いします　やふへゐ）はい
やっぱさすがにこれだとわかんないすね
手なんかね顔というか手が光りすぎててそこがすごい心配でした
周りにもバレなすぎるので次は1本全部行きます
やべ絶対使い方違う
ぶうううわああああ　うぅ
待ってやばい助けて誰か
やふへゐ）いいところに　はじめ）あ、ほんとですか
はじめ）どうすか？　やふへゐ）白に変えると
やふへゐ）何これ赤じゃん
やふへゐ）これですね
はじめ）ほーー
はじめ）あー
やふへゐ）はっはっはっはっはっはｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）なるほどなるほど
はじめ）あの、いい…あぁでも
はじめ）あのーそうですね、どうしました？
はじめ）あ、大丈夫ですか　やふへゐ）ｗｗｗ
はじめ）赤の方が良かったかもしんないですね一回見てみたかっただけで
やふへゐ）ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）そうっすねー　やふへゐ）赤で
はじめ）ドロップしたら赤でお願いします　やふへゐ）赤で　はじめ）はい
やふへゐ）了解しました
はじめ）じゃよろしくしやす
バレてない　すげーまだバレてなかったぞ多分
彼がバカなのかなんなのかわかんないすけど
これだけ顔がテカテカしててもバレてないんで
もうちょっといけると思います
顔と手にはもう塗れる場所がないんで
ちょっと身体全体的に塗っていきましょう
じゃもう2本追加でいきます
分かりづらいとは思うんですけど結構身体中今テカッテカしています
はじめ）お疲れっす　やふへゐ）お疲れっす
やふへゐ）今書き出して　はじめ）どうっすか？
やふへゐ）ちょっと待ってｗｗ
はじめ）あ、もう今書き出し中
はじめ）あーいいっすね
やふへゐ）サムネｗサムネあれですよね？
はじめ）あーそうですねサムネはあれで
はじめ）まぁー7時ちょっと過ぎくらいですかね？
やふへゐ）そｗｗｗそうですね
はじめ）まぁまぁまぁ　やふへゐ）大丈夫すか？
はじめ）多分…あぁ…
はじめ）まぁ大丈夫だと思います　やふへゐ）ふふふｗｗ
はじめ）よろしくお願いします　頑張って下さい
すげーバレてないっす
まだバレてない　カメラで伝わんないのが悔しいけど
バリッバリキラキラしてるんすよ身体中が
待って肌がキラキラ過ぎてやばい
もうやばいテカテカテカーしてるよ
これもうちょいいけるんちゃうかなー
待ってズボンがやばいズボンの輝きが
待って俺やばい終わったかこれ助けてください誰か
待って、なんか、肌が、痛い、肌が痛い
最後なんでもう全部使っちゃいます
はじめ）ウッス
はじめ）どうすか？
やふへゐ）ふふｗｗ
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】